[Music]
my aunt's name is charity
we named Jango after django reinhardt
the jazz musician so we try our best to
live sustainably and zero waste and
we've incorporated that into how we care
for Django so what made you guys decide
to try to make his own food and try to
limit the waste of your pet honestly it
was because of his health we were
feeding him dry cat food but Django
developed crystals bladder crystals they
are crystallized pieces of something
that can make it super painful for the
cat and dangerous too it can cause
blockages so he was not using his box
when he should have been that was our
first alert that something was wrong
he's all better now but the the vet
recommended that we stop dry food and do
a wet food only I found the recipe for
genuine line it was a Canadian vet
recipe it's basically ground chicken
ground chicken liver and some other
supplements with bone meal making cat
foods not something you can like come up
with your own recipe have to do of that
recipe because particular needs that cat
has but it's sort of mimics what they
were debt in the wild if they were
killing Birds we chose to make Django's
food from scratch because it's cheaper
and it's better for him when we were
feeding him the canned food it was
coming through about $150 a month and $5
a day with the homemade food it depends
on how much you can get the chicken for
but it's roughly a dollar seventy-five
or two dollars a day so it's about fifty
to sixty dollars a month which is still
expensive but it's much cheaper than
doing all transfers so his poop doesn't
smell so much anymore and his urine
doesn't not have that strong ammonia
smell anymore his coat is beautiful and
shiny and it's just been a really great
switch for him I would say he has more
energy and yes peppier and tearing the
porter french speak we use a pine litter
which is compostable we scoop out the
poop because in California it's not a
good idea to flush cat waste down the
toilet it can affect marine life we
usually put it straight in the black bin
and then the remainder of the litter
because it's made from pine
can go in the green bin and be composted
before we changed
Django's food before we started making
it homemade his cat box smelled like a
typical cat box and we tried different
kinds we tried a wheat litter we tried
to recycle
walnut shell walnut
these different kinds and the pine
letter we felt really kept the odor at
bay I have a business where people can
come and refill household cleaners and
body care products in a zero-waste
manner
it's called sustain la we hope to have a
storefront in the future where you can
buy litter package free because it's
really hard to find litter of package
free in fact the litter we that we chose
was originally in a cardboard box which
was great but now they've repackaged it
in a plastic bag a lot of litter comes
in bags that aren't recyclable and it'd
be great to have that source in bulk
there you want me to try it I've taken
the chicken broth chicken and baked it
for about 20 minutes
you know 350 degree oven which kills any
bacteria and this way Jango gets
benefits of a raw meat diet when Matt
went to the store he was able to ask for
the chicken in this container so we
received it paper package free which is
great I'm cutting the meat off the bone
if I had a better meat grinder you could
actually just grind grind the bone right
in and then you wouldn't have to use
bone meal and that will be a future
purchase we have to put bone meal and
with this recipe because there's a
particular ratio for I forget which
nutrients that they have to get from the
meat and the bone because when the birds
in the wild to crunch up their bones
we're like mostly vegetarian households
it was kind of funny
ok so I've cut all the chicken off the
bone here get the cooked liver
and I will turn on the noisy grinder
making sauces it's not pretty these are
all the supplements we're gonna finish
mixing here in with some water want to
get it all mixed in so give Django no
excuses to refuse the food for his
sensitive palate he's just a really
picky the dry stuff on top was the liver
i ground up the liver the chicken liver
this much food to last us about 10 days
you can do bigger batches because
usually about what I do you can keep it
in the fridge for like a day or two the
rest has to be frozen when we freeze
them in these little jars somebody's
excited
Django had an infection as a kitten he
was a rescue so he has a cartilage Spurs
in his nose and without the probiotics
he gets sinus infections let's eat you
don't want this for lunch
[Music]